we are going to begin though overseas
with new assurances from russia about
diffusing the situation in ukraine
assurances that have been met with
skepticism in this country and other
nato nations russia has released video
of what it says are some tank units
ending military drills but america
cannot verify the authenticity of the
claims and president biden is saying
that there are still as many as a
hundred and fifty thousand russian
troops surrounding ukraine on three
sides
of zhang is at the white house for us
wija good morning to you the president
seemed to make the case yesterday that
americans are going to feel what happens
in ukraine
yes he did he said we will feel an
impact and there will be a global impact
around the world the russian military
though says that it is starting to draw
down some of its troops near ukraine
even sending them back to their home
bases but that number you just mentioned
150 000 russian troops is the highest
one we have heard yet and president
biden says they remain in a threatening
position
we should give the diplomacy every
chance to succeed president biden
promised to do what he could to prevent
a war something vladimir putin claimed
he does not want during a meeting in
moscow with the german chancellor the
russian leader said de-escalation is
possible with the negotiation process
through peaceful means but mr biden is
not convinced an invasion remains
distinctly possible
defense secretary lloyd austin is in the
region meeting with leaders in nearby
poland lithuania and belgium the
president revealed there are now more
than 150 000 troops surrounding ukraine
up from 130 000 a few days ago i've been
clear
that if russia targets americans
in ukraine we will respond forcefully
president biden committed to securing
nato's eastern flank but he vowed not to
send american forces to fight in ukraine
insisting the administration is ready to
implement a devastating sanctions
package and senate lawmakers say they
are prepared to support those sanctions
if putin further escalates the democrats
think you should do a sanctions bill
announcing in advance what you would do
if there was an invasion the president
warned that sanctions on russia may hurt
americans too but the american people
understand that defending democracy and
liberty is never without cost i will not
pretend this will be painless
there could be impact on our energy
prices
the administration is looking at a
variety of ways to offset the already
high gas prices not ruling out a
possible break from the gas tax
meanwhile vice president harris is
heading to germany later this week for
the munich security conference the white
house says it will demonstrate the u.s
commitment to nato allies michelle
a lot on the table luigi thank you